we're better on a warm spring day to
discuss the viability of the demands of
the extinction rebellion there with a
panel including of former climate change
minister X Downing Street spin doctor
and the heads of a couple of
environmental think tanks in a garden
cafe on the banks of the Thames the
demonstrators are demanding the
government tells the truth about what
they called the climate emergency that
the UK has net zero carbon emissions by
2025 and that a citizen's assembly is
set up to lead the climate change agenda
our panel blows hot and cold on each if
that's having the truth means that
there's some sort of conspiracy of
silence
well that's complete nonsense and here
in the UK we've actually got a lot to be
proud of
I mean emissions are now 44% below where
they were in 1990 and I don't know of
any other major industrialized country
that's made so much progress as we have
in cutting emissions one of extinction
rebellions aims is simply to get people
talking about it more in the media in
politics and over there having those
sort of garden fence conversations and
you'd have to say from the evidence over
the last few days they're succeeding on
that
there's no point having a target that is
too easy because everyone will look at
that and say well this doesn't mean
anything at all we can do that standing
on our heads but nor is there any point
setting a target that is so implausible
that the whole process loses credibility
think to bear in mind is that climate
change however is like diabetes it's a
progressive disease if you don't do
something about it it goes on getting
worse so the later you start doing
something about the problem the worse
the eventual outcome will be for you I
think 2025 isn't really achievable there
are three waiting reports out there in
the last six months that tell us we can
do it by 2045 ish so you'd have to say
that you know it is a question of when
they've been used very successfully in
Ireland for example in Canada and
elsewhere around the world they do have
a role to play they can't make the final
decision but they can make
recommendations to government and
government if it's sensible would be
well-advised to listen to that advice
and commit itself to take it very
seriously but not necessarily to accept
all of the conclusions the takeaway
seems to be that there's merit to some
extent in two of the three demands but
zero-carbon in just six years
is a pipe dream but what do the protest
leaders make of a school all the problem
is it might be a pipe dream but it's the
only option we have left so if you want
to delay it five years sure but we're
not going to meet that deadline and
we've been pushing this back long enough
we need to make sure that we are doing
it by 2025 because otherwise there's no
other option so it's made your mind up
time for the protesters right wrong or
somewhere in between they're both on Sky
News in Westminster